vous aurez du mal à trouver des laitues
romaines et iceberg dans les kiosques du
marché Jean-Talon bah les prix sont un
peu exagérés si vous voyez ces 7 dollars
le prix est exorbitant et les laitues
d'une qualité discutable les maraîchers
les ventes ont space en le nez les
petits commerçants
ou peu passé elle est trop cher et notre
marge de profit et n'est pas là le
consommateur a guéri se tournera plutôt
vers des solutions de rechange comme les
laitues d'ici cultivées en serre
que j'ai pas acheté j'ai acheté d'autres
choses vous si on la jette Paul et
marchands pourront Paul avant de ce prix
là ça se résume en souffre juste pour
embarquer dans cette folie la cause de
l'augmentation des prix se trouve en
Californie ou la sécheresse a faciliter
le développement d'un virus qui a décimé
les récoltes de l'éthi romaine et
iceberg alors il y a eu des pertes
épouvantables présentement à la très
très bas sur les marchés il y a pas de
dessus avant ce distributeur de fruits
et légumes payaient habituellement 40
dollars la caisse de 24 pommes de laitue
il débourse maintenant entre 100 et 150
dollars la caisse je suis dans
l'industrie depuis au delà de 45 ans
j'ai jamais vu des prix tenir aussi
longtemps
c'est vraiment pas la même qualité qu'on
a généralement c'est tout petit un
véritable casse-tête pour ce restaurant
végétalien qui tente d'éviter la pénurie
depuis quelques semaines déjà
pour me dire qu'il y en avait juste pas
du tout pour la journée des chaînes de
restauration rapide comme Subway doivent
même diminuer la verdure dans leur repas
et les laitue pourraient s’avérer être
la pointe de l'isberg on ne subit des
hanches considérant pour le chou-fleur
le brocoli commence à monter les fraises
ont monté sans compter les tomates de la
Californie dont les prix devraient
également atteindre des sommets en
raison de la sécheresse ici
Jean-Philippe Radio-Canada Montréal